[Music]
Hey, I'm Will and with Noble Locksmith
and you're watching my YouTube channel,
Car Key Wizard. I'm an automotive
locksmith and while I definitely don't
know it all, I have learned some tricks
along the way that I hope will help you
while you're out in the field. One thing
you can do to help me out though would
be to subscribe to my channel. And if
you like my videos, leave a comment or
ask a question and I'll get back to you
as soon as I can. I make a lot of
videos, so if there's something you'd
like to learn more about or a video
you'd like to see on a car we're working
on, just let me know in the comments and
I'll put it up as soon as I can. Thanks,
and I hope you enjoy watching our
videos.
[Music]
>> All right, we have another Pacifica
uh we're going to be doing with the IM
608. Um, just a pro tip for you. Try to
remember that with these uh accessible
vans, when you open the sliding door
with the remote, with the double click
for the sliding door, the ramp comes out
and cracks you in your shin if you're
not expecting it.
Learned that lesson three times. Maybe
maybe next time I'll remember it and
then I crack my shin.
I'm going to remember someday. Today was
not that day. Let's see here.
We'll auto select this one. Chrysler.
So, a customer has two working keys,
one good, one bad. They both work except
for this key. The proximity function
doesn't work. The remote works. It will
start when you hit the start button with
the key, but the prox function doesn't
work for some reason. Um, I'm going to
add just add another key so she's got
it.
Um, I'm on the starport, which is in the
SE-pillar back here, and I had to rig
up. Pretty proud of myself for this one.
I had a very long extension. I can't
find it, but I found two other OBD
extensions. So, I've got one going into
the OBD into another extension
into the splitter, which then has the
star port on the other side.
the I was going to do it with the Smart
Pro because the Smart Pro you don't need
to actually be on the OBD for power. It
goes all through the Starport, but our
uh
Smart Pro we use tokens on. And I
figured
I'm pretty smart. I can figure out how
to make this work. And I did.
So, we did the auto select, pulled up
the VIN,
Let's
turn off. Don't kill the battery. One
thing I always do when I get in a car,
especially on a Chevy or Ford where
you're going to be doing a 10 to 12
minute wait, turn the AC off. Depending
if the car is going to have the ignition
on for a long time, I just do it
automatically when I get in. Turn the AC
off so you don't run the battery down.
All right, we're going to go control
unit. Read the password
off. Hazards on.
Done.
I do not have interwebs. That's
interesting.
Weird. Uh, I will be back in a second
here. I don't know why I wouldn't have
internet.
Okay, so we're back with internet.
Second time I've done that this week.
The Starlink, while it is an amazing
thing, does work better plugged in. I'm
adding a second monitor in the back of
my van for EPROM work and shuffling
stuff around there. I keep unplugging
the damn Starlink. So, we're
communicating 1 to 10 minutes for the
password. Shouldn't take too long, but
we will be back when that comes back.
All right, we have password 83462.
and go back to keyless system
key learning.
See number of keys. I would expect it to
be two. Four. Wow. I don't know what the
limit is on these.
See if email information tells me
does not. Well, we'll try to add one.
We're going to find out.
I think these are six, but honestly, I
just don't know.
Key learning. Key learning.
Please make sure the ignition is off.
Ignition is off.
83462. I'm glad that autopop populated
because I definitely forgot.
Hold the key near the start stop button
and complete procedure within 60
seconds.
Determine the key type.
Oh, this is a key sense casing.
This is my favorite part.
Current number of keys is five. Learning
successful. Do you want to learn the
next key? No, I do not. We are done. So,
I did not get a lock cycle that I heard.
Anyway,
but yeah, it did take that key. Here's
my key. Took the key. Um, this is a key
sense key. That's why it asked that last
part there. So, I did hit no because it
was a key sense key,
but we're good to go. My extensions
worked. And again, that ramp comes out.
Just saying it again, so maybe I'll
remember.